I remember a time I was living with this
fella and he used to Train we didn't
train cats but he would smoke some
marijuana and I would smoke some but I
didn't like smoking marijuana with this
boy mister Khin and his name with mr.
Ken and he actually did some karate and
he had some cats and he had these his
two cats had already lived with him and
then I moved in and took the second
bedroom so I don't have any say in the
cats I can't move in and I go what are
these cats doing here living with us
because the cats already lived there
they were his cats he was a cat owner
which is how that's even a real term in
the universe cat owner yeah for now dude
to mother nature [ __ ] strikes back
and they got lions eating [ __ ] you
know they got Lions gutting you know
just just chomping down on the spines of
the you know of whites and Koreans out
on the street out on the streets of
Memphis and streets of anywhere then
we'll see who's a cat owner you because
mother nature's about to [ __ ] [ __ ]
everybody up but anyhow Kent mr. Kim
would get high and he would make me come
out in the liver me to have all these
empty boxes stacked up and he would the
cats would climb up and get in the boxes
you know I guess one of them was kind of
a show cat and the other one was just
kind of a secondary cat that seemed a
little bit supportive of the first cat
and would do some of the same type mr.
Kent called him tricks I didn't think it
were tricks you know watching a cat when
I'm hired two cats getting into a box
that shit's [ __ ] stupid to me but I
guess I you know I felt I felt a little
scare to Ken because his do we do karate
in the house we're both adults man this
is if we were 30 so when you doing
karate in the house and you know you all
just just met you know there's
definitely there's something going on
there you know that's that [ __ ]
that's when somebody's nipping yeah
that's when somebody's catching a little
bit of the you know they might have a
little bit of you know they might have
the damn they might have a you know
something loose in their spine or
something and their brain still might
not be on 100 you know they might have
some of that uh ape glue or whatever
it's called keep
the brainstem locked into the spine but
he uh so anyway we I defer watch these
cats get high and whatever [ __ ] but
yeah that's what I'm talking about man
[ __ ] I forgot what is even talking about
just now
mother nature talking about the cat's I
was talking about I had that roommate
can and that fellow who oh you said it's
like a tiger it's like a cat man yeah I
don't think it's like going into
somebody's house and shooting a cat you
know I think it's just that oh oh oh I
was telling you this so Ken mr. Ken the
dude who I lived with one time I was
moving out I'm moving out of the place
right and nobody had come has seen the
apartment I'm showing the room he's been
advertising it because his name is on
the lease so I'm showing it and this hot
chick comes over and she she told she I
showed the room and I started flirting
with her man because I couldn't help
myself
you know sometimes I just cannot help
myself and and Ken told me oh I ended up
getting her number and Ken told me she
left he's like man she's really
interested in the place she seemed
really cool do not don't hook up with
this girl man do not hook up with this
girl and I said okay Ken I won't I
promise that I won't man and then a few
hours later whatever she and I are
texting I invite her out to do we went
and did something or whatever then she
came back to the place with me the room
she was considering renting and we made
love you know we made second you know we
made first degree or second degree love
cuz I don't like I told you man I don't
shift into high gears when it comes to
sex boy you know I'm saying I'm that
artful I got that artful Idol I got that
attack Idol but I don't have that third
and fourth gear you know I'm saying you
might find me strutting out in second
but you're not gonna see me in third or
fourth you know but but yeah I've ended
up banging this young lady you know and
Kim was pissed
Kim was pissed man
and I think actually she ended up giving
me the whatever the the claw whatever
the one is you got to get salt pills or
whatever to get rid of it's an infection
in your wiener but it's something you
can that you can get cured real easy
penicillin cures it they don't really
have it anymore but it used to be
popular back in the day and she and I
split a case of that but yeah you know
it's uh it's obviously been something
I've struggled with in the past and I
think it's just that I'm I have to you
know I feel guilty I don't know I don't
I just have to I need some attention
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one